yeah but again you mentioned a good
point we don't need microchips
look at what china's doing with their
facial recognition i mean
let's pull up the article i sent you
guys because we're finding out that why
way
tested artificial intelligence software
that could
recognize people if they were uyghur
minorities
and then immediately called the police
on them i mean there's look at this yeah
we have it from the washington post they
have a face scanning system
is that how you say that huawei tested
ai software that could recognize uighur
minorities and alert police
for those that don't know china is
currently operating concentration camps
with one million uyghur muslims detained
the chinese government is using using
them as cheap labor and harvesting their
organs
being able to use facial recognition to
identify them
is beyond what we have in in all the
nightmare dystopia movies we have
people put their hoods up and they run
and they hide and they see the cop go by
and they like duck their head guess what
in this world
there's going to be cameras everywhere
yeah and there's going to know where you
are and this is the same country
influencing our politicians this is the
same country
bragging that joe biden is compromised
financing the sons of politicians
sending out spies that help politicians
get elected here named fang fang
that are chinese professional geisha
honeypots
i mean for i mean they're in trouble
they're talking about microwave and
weapons
gene splicing super soldiers i mean
we're in a predicament
here that that's really major and
there's another article here yeah
see i think they what makes them
different from so you know you're
looking at it from
from the standpoint of their boundaries
right so that's a country and they're
acting as a sovereign and they're doing
no
no
no no no they have international so so
no but what i'm saying is is that
it could just as well be anywhere what
we're looking at is the p the power
people that are in charge the people
that are controlling let's say the
technology that are controlling all the
corporate resources right
they don't really know nationality right
yeah yeah yeah multinationals
right so like to me i don't care if my
oligarchs are
chinese russian or american no it
doesn't matter this is a really
important point as we just noted with
the pope story
it's it's it's operating a lot in china
but the interests are
these massive corporations
internationally so when you
and what concerns me and when you talk
about it in terms of returning to alex
jones show
well no no but when you say but when you
say things like the chinese it
it almost puts like a blame on that it's
china and and i it's sort of like when
trump calls it the china virus
right it's a kung flu to be correct
here but but i think that's that it
almost gives us perception of that it
really has to do with
their their nation and i don't think
that i think it's it's bigger than that
the people and and i think i don't know
if it was you who clarified this but
it's the chinese communist party
yeah okay it is and that's yeah yeah
yeah and very different that is the
thing when you say china i think a lot
of people just think
oh it's chinese no and i and and well
people
well when you look at the the uyghur
muslim concentration camps
there's even reports that many companies
like nike and apple benefit off of that
human slave
remember when mulan was at moulin where
they didn't requested the movie and they
thanked this paramilitary group that is
enslaving people
yes so that is in charge of watching the
uyghur muslims yeah well i call them
i call them eye slaves aren't they
called i slaves the people that make the
have iphones suicide nets suicide and
well you know they moved their factory
their factory used to be in
the city and then enough people were
protesting it and not liking it so then
they moved out into like the middle of
nowhere china and um there's a compound
that's where the ice leaves yeah
yeah man it's creepy world we live in
but you know the crazy thing is we all
are sitting here basking in the benefits
of this horrifying slave labor out of
out of uh out of these these camps
in these factories but it happens here
we just call it prison
oh definitely yeah i remember when kanye
said something about repealing the 13th
amendment
do you remember that i i don't listen to
kanye
well so let me try to avoid kanye let me
make sure i have uh
you know i think he's disturbed and i
also i'm not into celebrities that are
rich for being famous and famous
i understand your point no no no kanye
is the greatest musician of this or any
generation
that's why i'm kidding no i know he's
good i think he makes some good music
whatever i stay in your lane right right
so but no no i bring this up because he
tweeted that we should abolish the 13th
and everyone started going nuts
and what he meant was though the 13th
amendment allows slavery
if you're convicted of a crime so kamala
harris
she kept people in past their their
terms to use them as cheap labor but not
just that to fight
fires you're gonna risk your life for a
dollar an hour and we're not letting you
leave because we want you to be
our like they technically give them
shortened time but
um they were supposed to be already out
yeah well
it's just it's crazy and it's obviously
um it's slavery
this is slavery and no and he's right
the 13th amendment does that that is the
one thing
that clause is what has allowed our
corrections institutions to run away
with what it has like that's
that clause has been that but i mean
obviously abolishing the 13th amendment
would not be
no otherwise get rid of that right
but no it's true and that has allowed
this to go on for as long as it has we
need prison reform
we in this country we treat prison like
an opportunity for a big business and
that's because of the 13th amendment
it's a profit motive we need to not have
a profit it's because of too much
government and too much laws and too
many bureaucrats just making things up
to satisfy their their imaginable public
meanwhile they're working for the
corporation so
i i remember like growing up that the
right was very much like the government
is a problem the corporations are fine
and the left was like the corporations
of the problem the government is fine
and it's kind of like you know it's bad
people exploiting any kind of structured
system and they're doing a revolving
door between each other to make money
and exploit us
a corporation look you can have a small
business corporation yeah and you can
have a government of a small town of
2000 people and everyone's very happy
now when we say corporate
we're talking the big people exactly
okay i mean i yes technically
my little gen core is a corporation
we're not exploiting this exactly right
so no we're talking about when we say
government we mean the revolving door
policies of the military-industrial
complex and
big business the president-industrial
complex the big pharma industrial
complex we could keep going but i do
think there's a big agenda to keep
people divided keep people fighting each
other that's why there's a meme of
libertarians beating up other
libertarians and laughing at each other
yeah
and you know even though me and you
disagree like i got micro triggered when
you say collectivism
i'm sorry i'm messing with you i'm
joking i'm being pushy i'm being fishy
okay because i couldn't clarify what i
mean no no no i'm being very
nice i know i'm being very facetious i
always believe in decentralization but i
believe
it's more productive if we could
actually sit down and
listen to each other and learn from each
other rather than just try to win an
internet argument or try to be better
than each other
and that's why you know i thank you for
coming here and talking to us because i
think it's important to reach out to all
the disenfranchised people
and say hey man enough is enough let's
all come together and look at the
wrongdoings and evil we have a lot more
that we agree on that we don't exactly
we do and there's a big illusion to make
us not understand that yeah so we were
talking about watchmen a couple times in
the past few episodes are you familiar
with the graphic novel or the movie
okay i'm married i was the original
penny you know penny from big bang
theory
no you've never watched the biggest i
don't like pikachu okay well it's cheesy
but she's like this one girl that's
always in the comic book store and the
guy right
and so when i started dating my husband
he's upset he collects comics like he's
obsessed with comics so i was one of
those girls that would walk in the comic
book store and all the guys were like
what is she doing you know like like
crazy so now i'm very familiar with the
watchmen the movie was horrible though
can i say that
i like the movie um the graphic novel is
like a masterpiece with the exception of
what was it billy kudrow naked i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that the director's cut
they show it all okay see now
that made it worthwhile but no i mean i
just didn't so but you know like they
created uh
in the graphic novel the alien and fake
alien invasion yeah joe biden could be
that alien invasion
you're assuming that there's a there
there you're assuming that
it's there's something in there of joe
biden well yeah no
that's what i mean he's literally like a
mannequin standing like
he he's a he's a scare populist did you
see the little video
uh weekend at biden's have you seen this
yeah
it was beautiful it was amazing no no no
no no no but he's he's he's he's a
he's a scare populist they put him they
they strung him up on a little post
and all the left and the right pockets
are going ah i like looking at him you
know like he's bad
maybe this will be something that unites
are you saying you think biden's the
great unifier yeah that's what that's
well i mean jokingly
whether he realizes it or not by default
he's the he's the hapless
and uh i think he's crooked but also
okay but i think they're all crooked
yeah i do i mean you this is and that's
the thing when you want to sit there and
talk about like hunter biden and all
that please don't get started on like
trump's family and trump's kids it's
like
you're talking about an entire group of
people that by definition
are filthy to be where they are and
we're not in that group so it's kind of
like
that's just splitting hairs i think joe
biden
is just like almost nothing yeah you
know
like yeah it's a shell but he's using
that
shell he's there and the regular people
who are
you know paying attention starting to
wake up and get active to this
exploitation
they see him standing there in the wind
of the white house just on his post you
know
not really doing anything and they go
like ah like something's wrong here like
we got to do
it it's getting people active so i think
you know it's interesting how
aside from the weird woke left i guess
the and and they're often in alignment
with establishment the media
corporations they think that the
resistance or whatever
the the i i don't know i don't know what
you call the non-woke left but there's
like anti-war progressives they get
censored all the time
and they're very much i'm the non-woke
left but like the
the trump supporters hate war there was
a a i think it's the america he
campaigned on that
against war trump yeah yeah i know and
so now trump is like i think one of the
reasons he really wants to pull the
troops out of afghanistan is because
he wants to get as much support from
regular people as possible who hate war
so he's like i'm going to make it happen
but everybody hates war like luke was
saying earlier in the show
every president has campaigned on it
because it's popular people hate it it's
a waste of our energy
i always say this why are we at
allocating so much money to
any kind of foreign excursion or
intervention when that money could be
allocated to flint
fixing the pipes that's not a priority
or just
craziest thing because that hasn't
financially benefit the people in charge
and military does
building roads and creating economic
opportunity in these other countries
that make money for big corporations and
internationalists is
is good making sure that american
citizens are benefiting from
our community which guarantees them
clean water and not getting uh
legionnaires disease well that they
don't care about but that's a have to
talk about the collective then when we
talk about
clean water we have to talk about what's
in the best interest of the collective
the community
well that's what i mean when i say
collected well right you come together
as a society to have certain benefits
right
i think we need to come together as
disenfranchised people and then after
that
if we are successful you go on and do
your thing how you want to do it in your
place
i'll do it in my place
and we could have a decentralization and
we could have a commune that does it
in a communistic way and we could have a
capitalistic utopia that does it their
own way didn't just like that video game
that we talked about didn't ron paul say
this was a quote where he said
that in this system you're free to
create your own socialist
community yes yeah chaz you know oh yeah
yeah
well so i put it this way the reason why
i i really liked ron paul
um there were a lot of you know core
issues relating to like religion stuff i
didn't agree with but i remember when i
was younger i thought about it i was
like if he had his way
and he created his you know libertarian
type society
i could have my more left-leaning
community
with no one bothering us yeah you know
we can go do our thing your community's
poisoning earth's water
and destroying the air no but we were we
were the hippies like i worked for
greenpeace we're the people who were mad
about that and so we were like we wanted
to have our space that would protect and
isolate and you know like
isolate in a sense where it's like don't
come here don't mess with our you know
our clean water and air this is our
but you can have that in a more
libertarian society well the libertarian
idea is mainly
let be and and be as you want yeah and
as long as you're not
forcing other under individuals under
the threat of
violence that right to do something
we're okay but you know that
i always i always come to that problem
of like i've had conversations with
right anarchists or whatever what
happens if i've got a stream
for my community and then a mile
downstream some dude touched pooping in
it
you know yeah that's like causing
sickness and illness to my well you need
to know if they have
if they subscribe to the common law flow
of water or if they've got what's called
riparian rights and it depends on
whether you live on the river can you
buy water can you own it
um you can depend certain states have
what's called
riparian rights which means that the
person at the source is basically in
charge of what happens to what goes
downstream right but then some states
have it where you are in charge of what
the water is behind your own
property so there's it depends on the
state it's state law it's in my benefit
to work out my problems with my
neighbors accordingly and in a peaceful
manner and it's
way i rather have that problem than have
the military industrial complex creating
the worst humanitarian crisis in yemen
right now i agree with you so if you
have a choice right now yeah i'll argue
with my neighbor about where to poop
sure i'll do that gladly any day if it
doesn't mean bombing the crap out of
innocent people
the guy is like i'll put wherever i want
well there's different ways of
of defending yourself and dealing with
those problems and situations but
obviously being a sovereign you know
you would you know i would go one mile
upstream from him and start pooping in
his way
well and that is and that's ultimately
the problem with this kind of law yeah
is that there's there's no end it's like
leapfrog like you just keep moving up
and it's that's why even collectivism
and they can go pollute the air at will
you got to clarify that though
like you said you're joking but you go
over there with your gun and you got to
deal with it somebody but you got you
got to clarify i got to deal with you
somehow
you got to clarify what collectivism is
because what happens if two collectives
start shooting at each other you got
them they're not being collective
together they're not collecting when we
speak of the collective i'm talking
about whatever it is that
the substance that we're all paying
taxes to one of the that's
yeah one of the biggest arguments
against uh anarchism or libertarianism
is that a bunch of crazy war mongers are
going to take over
well look what happens now look what
this look at the system that we have now
so i would think there would be less
harm i would think there would be less
problems
once we decentralize power and we don't
have psychopaths with nuclear weapons
that uh essentially start wars for
profit but who's to say that the
decentralized communities wouldn't build
nuclear weapons
yeah they might build crazier weapons
actually no joke because the the
regulations would be would be extremely
different so
when they have the resources do they
have the money without a centralized
force it would be very different no no
one of the reasons why the u.s
accelerated and a lot of crazy
technology was because of a lack of
understanding and regulation
so you had people doing crazy
radioactive experiments so the
government creates this overarching
lockdown
like you if like doing research on lsd
the whole government's locked it down if
you had disparate pockets of collectives
there could be one place where they're
like you're free to do whatever you want
in that regard another place saying you
can't do that
that's like states yeah you already have
that with states
yeah no but i mean like the federal
government has locked down a lot of a
lot of specific things
well they lock it down when it doesn't
benefit them financially or they can't
gain control over it we could still have
a mutual
defense agreement with all the different
states but i believe that individuals
should determine how they want to live
their lives and i think us getting more
involved in local
issues local community politics is the
way to do
it and then when we have this big over
compensating federal government
we have to limit that as much as we can
but we could still have a national
defense and we could still live under
the rules of anarchy or libertarianism
or socialism or communism depending on
the community
that determines what's right for them
and their particular circumstance
because
again the biggest minority is the
individual that's the one that we think
we should always look out for over
anyone else thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you